[موسيقى]
جمال الروح
بالقطعه القديمه بالنسبه الي انا شخصيا
يعني
انا طبعا اكثر وقتي من اخلص شغلي وعملي
اجيب البيت انا قليل الخروج حقيقي من بعد
العمل اقعد هذا مكاني بين طويله
واصدقائي اللي يجون ايضا هم حتى من يطلع
من يمي يكون نفسيا مرتاح طاقه ايجابيه
انا متعتي مو بصفقه تجاريه لا المتعه دي
مثلا حصل لي على قطعه مثلا سيف قديم اسد
الله الغمد ماله رايح بس النصل
القبضه منتهيه البرشق اللي هو بين القبضه
والنصل
اجي اقعد اخابر اهل الاقتصاص وياي نتناقش
هذا السيف شلون نعيده الى وضعه
فتاخذ مني شهور هذا الحكي شهور ومتونس اني
وصبور
يعني الى ان اكمله رجع ال السيف كما كان
طبعا نستعين بالنت نرجع للتاريخ بالزمن
التاريخي شلون كان مثل الغمد ماله
حتى نقدر نطبق الاصل اما باقي الاشياء
القبضه او البرشق هو قديم هاي الدله كلش
معتز بيها
جدا هاي قطعه من القطع الثمينه اللي
لاقيها صعوبه في الحصول عليها القطعه
السعوديه حقيقه
خلينا نقول ايام
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في بدايه
تاسيسها انت بها شعار المملكه والسيف
والنقش النقش النجدي الجميل هذا
هاي طبعا كلش معتز بيها هاي ايضا الخوذه
محتفظ من اجمل مقتنيات يعتبرها اللي هي
الحقبه الايوبيه خوذه خوذه الجندية هاي
العهد الايوبي وهاي قطعه
امريكيه
تخص امراء حائل
عبد الله الرشيد طبعا هذا اسمه والهديه
الى
قطعه جدا سمينه حقيقه يعني جدا ثمينه
خاصه بعبد الله الرشيد خاصه بامير حائل
الصناديق القديمه التراثيه السيسم يعني
اللي
من من مقتنيات الجميله طبعا انا كذا صندوق
قديم
هذا الجهاز العروس وقبل هاي مجردين صندوق
واحد
الراديونات
الاجهزه الصوتيه الراديونات تقريبا
من اربعين الى 45 جهاز من شتى الموديلات
من 1930
الى الاربعينات فقط هاي الحقبه اللي يجمع
بها الراديونات واغلبها شغاله وتشتغل احد
الراديونات اللي يسمع بيه انا راديو مفضل
اللي حطها هناك كان عندك
انا عندي مجموعه سيوف حقيقه عربيه اصيله
الدبان يصلحوا لها
الشغل اسد الله الشغل اسد الله اللي هو
خلينا نقول نهايه
نهايه الدوله العباسيه الرابعه
تقريبا
وهذا مثلا السيف يصحوا فتياني
هذا السيف فتياني هذا مو للقتال الاستعراض
السيف القتال يكون شوي اعرض بطول اكثر
عندك هاي قطعه ايضا
قطعه من مسدس جولد
بداياته بدايه تصنيعه هاي القطع بيها نقوش
عديده الحقيقه هي هاي قطعه من مزاده اخذته
من هولندا
من القطع الاولى هذا عشر قطع بالعالم
انتجت شركه جولد بمناسبه ذكرى
الحرب الاهليه الامريكيه بين الشمال
والجنوب فانقتل جنرال جنرال شمال فسوله
تذكار عشر قطع باسمه هذا احد يعني
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات